hey youtubers is Charlie so Robbie Amell
has just been cast as the Ronnie Raymond
firestorm on season one of the flash I
know everyone really wanted him to be
Nightwing on arrow but this is gonna be
just as cool trust me so this video is
gonna be a breakdown of the character as
well as how I think he's going to
integrate with team flash and arrow
crossovers Amell Wednesdays are totally
making a comeback hello any new people
if you're just finding me for the first
time I'm doing arrow and flash bonus
videos all summer long be sure to
subscribe to get everything if you
really want to travel down the
arrowverse YouTube rabbit hole I have
some extra links in the description so
somebody blue one of their genie wishes
and Robbie Amell was brought into the
arrowverse he's actually gonna debut as
Ronnie Raymond and will eventually
become firestorm there have been a bunch
of different versions of that character
from the comics but Ronnie Raymond is
the original one so what is his origin
story you ask Ronnie Raymond was a high
school student who was caught in a
nuclear explosion with Nobel
prize-winning physics professor Martin
Stein as a result of the explosion they
fused to form firestorm the nuclear man
or the firestorm matrix depending on how
you want to think about it because
professor Stein was unconscious whenever
the blast happened Ronnie Raymond
essentially became the driving force of
the firestorm character and professor
Stein became like this ghostly talking
head so a lot of the fun moments from
the character came from the witty banter
between the two of those characters
whenever they were stuck inside
firestorm think of it as like Tony Stark
cracking wise with Jarvis whenever he's
inside his Iron Man suit and then that
heads-up display so this all happened
back in the late 1970s that's when he
debuted in the comics then this really
big thing happened in the DC Universe
where they canceled most of their
ongoing series it was actually called
the DC implosion
after that firestorm the character was
written into the Justice League and then
later he got his own short stories at
the end of the flash comics sometimes
they do that with the really popular
comics they'll give lesser characters
like their own little stories at the end
of the really popular ones so there's
actually a long history of firestorm
being paired up with the flash so it's
kind of historic letting that character
debut on the flash show instead of on
arrow
even though arrow is technically the
bigger show right now so yes the flash
takes place in central city but the
firestorm character was mostly seen
around
obesity in New York here's where we
start to cross over with arrow the new
character Brandon Roth is playing on
that show is Ray Palmer his version of
the atom he was a professor at Ivy
University in Ivy City after Ronnie
Raymond graduated from high school he
went to Ivy University and studied under
Ray Palmer arrow and the flash will
probably change their backstories a
little but even when they mess with the
comic book stuff they're always really
good about including all that stuff as
Easter eggs from the comics arrow has a
long tradition of putting signs on buses
and using street names for Easter eggs
so what about the firestorm character
isn't it supposed to be two different
people are they going to do that on the
flash so the actual character of
firestorm is the physical person you're
looking at when he's flying around the
firestorm matrix is what the combination
of two people are whenever they're
operating firestorm think of it as like
a transformer combiner it's like Ronnie
Raymond and professor Stein are
Constructicons x' and they combine to
form Devastator one person is capable of
being firestorm by himself but professor
Stein in the comics speculated that the
firestorm matrix was not designed to be
operated by just one person and then
later in the comics whenever Ronnie
Raymond was being firestorm by himself
he ended up causing this huge accident
when it became unstable whenever that
happens to firestorm whenever he becomes
unstable he causes a massive nuclear
explosion which is obviously really
really bad think of it as being like the
particle accelerator explosion in times
10 so you're asking how is the flash TV
show gonna deal with this character
they're probably not gonna do the
two-in-one thing but if they decided to
make firestorm the combination of Robbie
Amell and a STAR Labs person they might
make it look like a Tony Stark inside
his Iron Man suit thing you know
whatever he's talking to Jarvis heads-up
display if that's the case the closest
analogue for professor Stein that
they've established on the flash already
is the Tom Cavanagh character but if
you've seen the flash pilot you know
that they're probably not going to do
that they're probably doing something
else with the Tom Cavanagh character I
don't think he's gonna be the professor
Stein person I think they're just gonna
make it simpler and make Robbie Amell be
firestorm by himself
Aaron the flash already have made a lot
of changes to the backstories of certain
characters but I do feel like they're
gonna tease him going nuclear if he
can't learn to control his powers
so what are his powers specifically in
the comics he has the ability to
reorganize the atomic structure of
anything that has mass so any object can
be turned into any other object but he
does have to obey the laws of
conservation of energy so the new things
he creates have to have the same mass as
the original objects he can't turn say
like a rock into a car so whenever
you're thinking about firestorm making
things with his powers or rearranging
atoms and making new things think of it
as like the great lanterns making
constructs with their rings only it's
permanent the Green Lantern constructs
only lasts as long as the Green
Lantern's are thinking about them once
firestorm se turns your headphones into
a keyboard and flies away the keyboard
doesn't disappear it stays a keyboard oh
and yeah he can fly he'll be the first
character on the flash that we have that
can fly unless they introduce someone
before him that could fly technically
the flash is fast enough to run on air
but just in the comics I don't think
they're gonna do that on the show I
don't think we're gonna see Grant Gustin
running through the clouds
so how is the show going to handle the
firestorm origin story it all goes back
to that particle accelerator explosion
due to Robbie amell's age being pretty
much the same as all the other
characters in the show it's possible
that they could either make him a star
Labs technician or a normal person
living in Central City who was just
caught in the blast do you expect there
to be lots of Easter eggs from the
firestorm comics whenever they do tell
that origin story since firestorm is a
hero and not a villain it's easy to
assume that he'll eventually work with
team flash even if he's not a series
regular it's possible that in the grand
tradition of arrow they could wait till
the mid-season finale to introduce the
character they probably will reveal
something about that at Comic Con like
they'll tell us which episode he's gonna
debut in so just based on the CGI from
the flash pilot I'm really excited to
see how they manifest firestorm powers
on screen I think it's gonna look really
cool but at least for now they have
tuned down the level of the Flash's
powers from the comics so they might do
the same thing with firestorm there is a
precedent in the comics for the flash
being limited to certain speeds when
he's the only flash around he can tap
into more of the Speed Force and go
faster the Speed Force is like a faucet
if two flashes are drinking from it at
the same time each of them gets less
power so they both run slower if Barry
is the only flash in town
he can run so fast that he can travel
through time so whenever that first
episode debuts if you think he is
running slow it might be because
professor zoom is nearby the funny thing
about firestorm is that almost anybody
can merge with Robbie Amell to form the
firestorm matrix people that merge do
not retain memories of what they did
while they were part of firestorm until
their firestorm again so if Robbie Amell
say sucked in Cisco Ramon to make
firestorm when they split again Cisco
would not remember being firestorm until
they merged again I'm interested to see
if the show plays with this idea they
just have Robbie mail merge with a bunch
of different characters and all those
characters they just have no idea of
what they just did but when are we gonna
see a full-on firestorm probably not
right away just like Kara did with Barry
Allen they introduced the human first
then they turned him into the superhero
because they've already shot the pilot
episode and the STAR Labs explosion
happened nine months ago in the timeline
they might have to wreck on the story a
little if they want Ronnie Raymond to
become firestorm for the first time
during season one or they could tell his
origin story in a flashback either way
it's gonna be really exciting but I did
say that Robbie Mills character and
brain and Ralph's character on arrow
have a common history
what about crossovers those characters
had a common origin in the comics but
don't be surprised if err on the flash
find some sort of common ground for
their backstories even if they change
the comic book characters they haven't
said which bits from the comics that are
gonna be incorporating into the atom and
the firestorm characters yet but they're
usually pretty good about setting that
up in the first couple of scenes to
feature the characters so whenever
Brandon Ralph and Robbie Amell appear
for the first time on screen you'll know
pretty quickly where they came from and
what their origins are just as an
example of something really big that
arrow has already changed Felicity Smoak
was Ronnie Raymond stepmother in the
comics obviously Emily BETT Rickards
version of the character isn't going to
be Robbie Amell stepmom but it's
possible the show could use MIT is a
common point of origin for them it's
just my opinion but if Brandon rouse
character is supposed to be a tech
genius it only makes sense and if Ronnie
Raymond is supposed to be connected to
STAR Labs then also connecting him to
MIT isn't a big stretch so will Robbie
Amell be on arrow or have any scenes
with Stephen Amell on screen probably
not at first right now we really only
know for certain Stephen Amell is gonna
be on the flash at least in the first
couple of episodes the
other characters will probably cameo
eventually but until robbie amell is
introduced in his own flash episode and
starts to develop his relationship with
those characters do not expect him to
interact with any of the arrow
characters but yes the really big
question is TV Justice League team up I
do think that both shows will build
towards a mega team-up episode hopefully
by the end of this season
I do understand if they can't make it
work right away but hopefully at least
by flash season two and arrow season 4
will see all of these characters in the
same episode so whichever you guys burn
that genie wish to get Robbie Amell on
the flash just burn one more and we'll
get our TV Justice League arrowverse
team up and I know that everyone wants
to see the TV characters in the movies
but that's not really the way Warner
Brothers is doing things they're not
Marvel so even though Clark Gregg and
Sam Jackson get to bounce back and forth
it doesn't mean stuff owned by a
different studio Warner Brothers in this
case will work the same way but that
does not mean that they cannot do their
own Justice League with the TV
characters so now it's your turn let me
know in the comments below how long do
you think it's gonna be before we get to
see Robby melon like full-on firestorm
costume and when do you think that arrow
is gonna do the big Justice League team
up with those TV characters so in
related news there is a whole bunch of
comic-con stuff happening next week be
sure to subscribe to get all my videos
I'm gonna be doing a whole bunch of
different giveaways for each of the TV
shows and movies and stuff that I do
I'll explain that whenever I start
posting those Comic Con videos though in
the meantime click here to learn about
Brandon routes Adam character and click
here to learn about the katana
characters they're both coming to arrow
season 3 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you